our series earth 365 focuses on issues
that affect our world year round this
morning the important role of get this
oysters yep oysters and the health of
our oceans and our seas too the reefs
where oysters grow are one of the
planet's most at-risk marine habitats
just in Florida more than 70 percent of
oyster reefs have disappeared in the
last century but one group is trying to
reverse that decline near Pensacola Mark
straussman brings us a story of what you
could call a marine rebirth
growing a three inch oyster
traditionally a wild oyster three inches
takes three years Pasco Gibson a
commercial fisherman grew up on these
Waters off Florida's Panhandle its
oysters used to feed his family that
stopped a decade ago zero industry today
nothing nothing no commercial Harvest of
wild oysters oysters matter we eat them
their an estuaries cleaning crew one of
those oyster filters 50 gallons a day
oyster beds break waves protect
shorelines from erosion and create
habitats for fish crabs and shrimp but
for commercial fishermen Florida's Gulf
Coast is no longer their oyster what we
didn't see is oyster habitat and Birch
works for the nature conservancy a
global conservation group steering a
multi-million dollar project to
resurrect oysters here clearly
everything was in rough shape yes and
the oil spill only in against it
day 44 the latest attempt to contain the
spill hits a new snack and the oil
spreads ever closer to Florida crude oil
gushed like a gaping wound into the Gulf
for nearly five months in 2010 and I
remember watching it bleed ashore all
this oil this is so heavy I can barely
lift it
is part of a 16 mile slick that currents
out here in the Gulf are now pushing to
land BP was found criminally and civilly
liable the company had to fund a 20
billion dollar compensation fund for
affected States like Florida 13 million
of that paid to restore these oyster
reefs even though oil never reached
these Waters late last year cranes on
barges began building oyster reefs no
one could guarantee the oysters would
give these Waters a second chance oyster
larvae needs something to cling to like
rocks then grow on top of each other
think oyster condos this is exactly what
we want to see at low tide Birch and I
waited out to one of the 33 new reefs
they stretch almost seven miles this is
a rock from one of the restored oyster
reefs that have one two three four five
six
seven eight oysters already settled on
it these oysters will be for habitats
not harvesting no commercial fishing
about that Pasco Gibson says there was
Zero Community pushback I don't want to
see the place I grew up where I still
make a living today
go away already noticing a big
difference I already noticing a big
difference as soon as next summer Gibson
hopes commercial fishermen will see fish
in greater numbers here conservation is
a long game evaluating meaningful
progress here will take years do you see
some poetic justice that this
environmental restoration is the
outgrowth of an environmental disaster
well certainly it is really important to
use that money in the way that will
restore the system that was harmed maybe
for the first time building Coastal
condos means environmental progress
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman Santa
Rosa County Florida